volley moeurs numéros pairs de clanisme
d'abord noté 6 63 84
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment que non l'apollon n'était pas
un suprémaciste blanc
il n'avait aucune idée préconçue d'été
ni raciste ni esclavagiste il a rétabli
effectivement l' esclavage ou du moins
il l'a maintenu dans certaines villes
mais ne l'a pas fait ni à l'île maurice
ni à l'île de la réunion ni surtout dans
les comptoirs des indes
[Musique]
stupide napoléon est l'un des plus
grands hommes au monde
napoléon est admirée à l'étranger faut
pas s'y tromper les français adorent
napoléon c'est simplement une partie de
la caste politique qui a accès aux
médias qu'ils essaient de lui tordre le
cou en france effectivement il ya une
toute petite minorité qui essaient de en
fait de déstabiliser la société
française en essayant de déboulonner aux
profs d'ailleurs comme au figuré
tous les grands personnages de
l'histoire c'est l'homme le plus célèbre
bon le français le plus célèbre au monde
napoléon garde une aura et un prestige à
travers bien sûr la majorité la
population française mais surtout je
vous le disais à l'étranger
[Musique]
sans aucun conteste napoléon a influencé
forcément la société et s'il fallait
donner qu'un seul exemple qui nous
touchent au quotidien ce sont les lycées
les lycées avec le baccalauréat s'est
montré qu'avec l'éducation
eh bien on peut parvenir à s'élever
c'est l'ascenseur social ena plan
lui-même en est un des plus beaux
représentants c'est donc que la
méritocratie avec la légion d'honneur
par exemple que la méritocratie est
installé durablement dans la société
napoléon a gagné 40 bataille il disait
on les oubliera peut-être ce qui me fera
rentrer dans l'éternité c'est le code
civil et le code civil qui a été
toilettée d'à peine 25 % c'est donc que
ça a plutôt été pas mal conçu
[Musique]
absolument non toutes ces histoires
d'empoisonnement cdc des fumisteries on
est sûr et certain que la mort de
napoléon était naturel à la à l'issue de
sa mort le 5 mai dès le lendemain
plusieurs autopsies sont faites à la
fois par les français et les anglais ils
concordent pas forcément toujours mais
on est sûr qu'il est mort effectivement
d'inscrire au pilote qui est devenu une
sorte de conserve ses re il est mort en
fait d'un cancer de l'estomac comme son
père et je crois qu'il a aussi et
surtout mort d'ennui finalement
d'apollon et mort quasiment des mêmes
conditions que sa soeur elisa ou que
même son père était mort en 1786
[Musique]
bien sûr bien sûr parce que les archives
s'ouvre de plus en plus et aux
historiens d'aller travailler d'aller
révélé certaines choses napoléon a été
étudiée sous toutes ses coutures
mais il reste encore dans les archives
privées et même certains éléments qui
n'ont pas été étudiées et c'est tout le
sens justement du travail à la fois des
historiens et des chercheurs de pouvoir
nous révéler des pans entiers napoléon
en plus on le connaîtra mieux plus plus
on aimera séparé sera utilisé sa toile
un prochain quand on parle de napoléon
ce n'est pas uniquement que lui en tant
que personne mais s'élançant de cette
période qui a tellement compté à la fois
pour l'europe mais pour le monde entier
[Musique]
ça c'est sûr le film avec ridley scott
que va diriger vite les scot avec
joaquim phoenix montre bien que napoléon
continue d'impressionner et de fasciner
et il faut se rappeler que pour les
américains
ça va être finalement une continuité
bien sûr chaplin avait envisagé de faire
un napoléon et finalement il va
abandonner l'idée parce qu'on est en 39
stanley kubrick devait tourner sur
napoléon où tout était prêt d'ailleurs
la chaîne en a fait un très beau livre
et ils malheureusement il n'a pas fait
kubrick avait imaginé et puis va
l'abandonner pour faire barry lyndon et
donc lui bien sûr en faisant un film de
cette manière eh bien il va faire avec
joaquim phoenix finalement ridley scott
la continuité d'un autre film qui
l'avait fait en 77 appelé les duellistes
qui finalement est dans les dna polonia
complète qui montrent que avec du
panache et avec de l'enthousiasmé on
peut déplacer des montagnes et que
l'histoire est véritablement fait pour
ceux qui sont avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé
[Musique]